the One Piece manga just dropped an
absolute bombshell by revealing the true
origin of devil fruits that's no one
expected in fact Oda might just have
broken the fourth wall and written
himself into the story and because it's
gonna be really important to discuss
this I want to give you the literal
translation of what Dr vegapunk tells
the straw hats in the original Japanese
version because when he sees gear 5 and
realize it that Luffy's devil fruit
takes the form of the god Nika he says
this you have probably not heard the
name Mika before because it's a name
that was erased from history however as
long as people keep wishing for him he
can never be erased everything is born
into this world after it was wished for
and the same goes for devil fruits
people go like if things only were like
this or if only that thing happened so
devil fruits are powers of a wide range
of wishes for Humanity's future and
therefore these artificial fruits are
hated by the mother of nature which is
the sea that is my personal hypothesis
I'm not even thinking about whether
there are gods or not isn't that
fascinating so devil fruit users are
actually beings created from someone's
imagination that lived in a different
dimension yes bigger Punk well that is
pretty fascinating holy usop this is by
far the biggest lore drop that we've
ever had about devil fruits in the
entire story really something that we've
been waiting for ever since the
beginning of Luffy's Adventure there is
so much that we need to talk about here
because this answers a ton of questions
we had but at the same time as one piece
often does raises even more new
questions as well okay devil fruits are
actually beings created by someone's
imagination living in another dimension
Oda did you just write yourself into the
story we need to discuss this however
the first thing before we can even get
into the meats and potatoes of this that
we need to address here is the big
caveat that vegapunk gives us here
because all this information that he
just dumped on us is his own personal
hypothesis in other words vegapunk
himself has deduced as much from all his
research and the research made by the
archaeologist on O'Hara but he does
acknowledge himself that it's not
confirmed to be the whole story and so
knowing Oda I believe that there is a
lot of Truth to what vegapunk has just
said here but I'm also convinced there
will be a few twists and turns to this
explanation in the end as well so take
everything here with a bit of a grain of
salt but with that being said let's go
through everything that we've gotten
here because
it's a lot basically vegapun's
hypothesis states that devil fruits are
created from people's imagination and
wishes for the future and as long as
people keep wishing for these things to
happen they will become real in the
world of One Piece now his example here
is actually Luffy's Nika devil fruit now
vegapunk actually didn't seem to know
that this particular devil fruit existed
in the first place he does look up the
gomugomonomi in the ancient devil fruit
encyclopedia yes that's a thing too
apparently that we'll have to talk about
at some point as well and he does
realize that there never was a
gomukomunomi however apparently vegapunk
has either seen an actual image of the
Sango Nika or heard a description of its
appearance because he correctly
identifies that Luffy's gear 5 is Nika
based on some ancient text that he
references once again I do have to
wonder whether all these ancient things
that vegapung references are all dating
back to the void century and to joyboy's
time or if all of this goes back even
further than we all imagined after all
the void Century happened only 800 years
ago while the one piece history itself
dates back back at least several
thousand years and then in this context
as of course also the entire Luffy
versus Lucci thing and Lucci's awakened
devil fruit having the same steam coat
around his body as luffin Yamato in
general this chapter answers a bunch of
questions we had about devil fruit
Awakening and how it works I think and
especially with all the new information
that we've gotten there is a lot that we
can deduce especially about Zone devil
fruits and I really want to discuss all
of that in detail so how about this I
will make a dedicated video about just
that that will be out within a week if
at least 1 000 people subscribe until
tomorrow anyways vegapunk basically says
that even though Nika's name and the
true name of Luffy's devil fruit were
erased from history by the world
governments the powers of sun god Nica
will never cease to be as long as people
believe in his existence now as we know
from who's whose small history lesson
Nika is a deity that's worshiped by
slaves as the warrior of Liberation in
other words Nika would be the literal
embodiment of people Wish For Freedom
which of course fits in perfectly with
the main theme of one piece and what
Luffy in general represents as a
character Freedom another thing that is
really interesting is that it turns out
that Blackbeard was actually being quite
literal when he said that dreams never
die he actually wasn't being all that
philosophical at all he knows that
people's dreams literally never die as
they're gonna be reborn as devil fruits
as long as people believe in them in the
end it turns out that this sentence too
was a major piece of foreshadowing that
Blackbeard had knowledge about devil
fruits that no one else had and this is
pure speculation but it might be the
case that this is the key to
Blackbeard's ability to steal devil
fruits as well I mean maybe the darkness
fruit is the strongest devil fruit in
his eyes because if there is Darkness
there can be no other dreams while you
sleep maybe exactly how this devil fruit
can cancel out other devil fruit powers
and why Blackbeard never sleeps in as
well I've previously also talked at
length about the fact that devil fruits
might well be related to inherited will
inherited will in one piece basically
describes handing down one's own wishes
and dreams to another person which means
that the countless examples of devil
fruits apparently changing people's
personality might well be due to the
will of previous owners being stored
inside them for example big man becoming
a lot more like mother caramel or Sabo
becoming a lot more like Ace and all of
this also seems to be connected to the
so-called lineage factor that was
discovered also by Dr vegapunk that
seems to be essential to the functioning
of devil fruits inherited will lineage
factor and now all of this of course
gives extra special meaning to Roger's
final words at his execution inherited
will the winding of the ages and the
dreams of people as long as people
continue to pursue the meaning of
freedom these things will never cease to
be well if what Vega Punk says is true
then this might be Roger describing the
secret of devil fruits in the very first
chapter of One Piece people dreaming of
a better future and passing those dreams
onto others which then again literally
keeps devil fruits in circulation across
the ages and the winding of the ages
itself might refer to the wide variety
of Futures of humanity that people wish
for that vegapunk talks about as well
and really everything that's being said
in this chapter fits in perfectly with
what both Blackbeard and Roger have set
only that dreams have a much much more
literal power in the world than we all
thoughts now the reason that I said that
no one is expected this reveal at the
beginning of this video is not because I
believe that no one ever had the idea
that devil fruits might possibly be
based on people's dreams in fact you
probably thought to yourself what do you
mean unexpected I thought of that ages
ago and in fact I myself made a video
over half a year ago talking about
exactly that possibility that devil
fruits might be created from Human
imagination but the reason that I found
this reveal so incredibly unexpected at
this point in the story was because so
far eckhead Island had basically one big
message for us and that is everything in
one piece that looks like magic actually
is ancient lost technology basically the
idea that I've been getting from
vegapunk so far is that everything
that's strange in one piece can be
explained by a technologically super
Advanced civilization that tapped into
an unlimited energy source that then
allowed him to basically do anything I
mean we do know that vegapang was able
to create artificial devil fruits using
science and it fits in very nicely with
the idea that all of this is just super
Advanced biotechnology and now suddenly
the main Science Guy himself of the
story tells us that actually if you just
wish for something hard enough it will
come true in this world I mean I'm not
sure about you but to me that just feels
incredibly paradoxical which one is it
now are devil fruits and hockey magic or
is it science and vegapunk himself
actually addresses this question too
remember he said that he doesn't really
care whether this is the work of gods or
a Gods which in other words means that
he actually doesn't know how wishes and
dreams actually become reality which you
know sounds a little bit fishy to me
don't you think that the man who wants
to know anything about the world and
ancient powers and wants to advance
science would not want to find out how
they worked and where they came from in
the first place a little bit fishy I
think either vegapunk is salty he
couldn't figure it out by himself or he
is actively withholding some important
information here after all in order to
create an artificial functioning devil
fruit in a lab he clearly must have at
least some scientific understanding of
these fruits for example Momo's perfect
devil fruit was created by using kaido's
lineage Factor basically the equivalent
of DNA in the one piece world so not
exactly magic right also vegapun
contradicts himself a little bit in his
speech when it comes to this point as
well he talks about how the sea which is
apparently the mother of nature how this
sea hates these artificially created
things and the two Japanese words that
Oda uses here are shizen and fujisen
which basically means nature or natural
and unnatural or artificial so basically
he openly describes these manifested
Powers as artificial Creations so which
one is a vegapunk my best guess right
now would be that someone actually had
the advanced technology or the
supernatural magic power to create this
mechanism in the one piece world at some
point in the ancient past and the key to
that is vegapung's most interesting
statement of all here
which first of all is such a strangely
phrased sentence just for confirmation I
actually asked some of my Japanese
friends to help me translate it and
everyone kind of said something
different here but here is the gist
ability users are people who live in
many different dimensions that someone
envisions ijigen literally means
different dimensions without any doubt
so this already is a big deal One Way Or
Another We're talking about different
dimensions in the one piece world but it
seems like Oda is keeping this a little
bit vague on purpose here and this could
mean so many things is it the actual
fruit users themselves who live in a
different dimension because to me it
does seem that they very much live right
here right now in the one piece world or
is it that those different dimensions
are created by someone and that devil
fruit users can access them and their
beings to use those powers or does it
mean that there are people from another
dimension who Envision a certain ability
and then that ability materializes in
the one piece World which would
basically mean that Oda imagining these
powers in our dimension in our reality
makes them a reality in one piece so Oda
saying that for him one piece is a real
world and that vegapunk is actually
aware of the fact that our real world
exists which uh honestly would be the
most meta Rick and Morty twist that Oda
could possibly pull off on us honestly
these reveals are just getting crazy and
crazier and in case you missed my
thoughts on last week's chapter make
sure to check that one out right here